les professionnels et les connaisseurs
l'appelle la p o
comprenez permanence opérationnelle plus
communément appelé la police du ciel
derrière ces deux lettres deux avions
des mirage 2000 et deux pilotes prêts à
décoller à n'importe quelle heure du
jour ou de la nuit pour assurer la
défense du territoire français ils ont
priorité absolue sur tous les autres
vols cette structure et cette permanence
fait que nous sommes prêts à tout type
de menace
nos équipages sont prêts à prendre en
compte tout type de menace ils savent
que régulièrement et c'est fort heureux
il décolle pour une mission qu'on
appelle ou de pratique c'est à dire
d'entraînement mais opérationnel comme
si c'était la reine mais si jamais la ya
effectivement d'abord un aéronef a
assisté ce cas une mission réelle mais
d'assistance
et puis si jamais il ya ni assistance
apportée et ni menaces il ya un scénario
il va jusqu'au bout du scénario
dès que l'alerté donnée les six
mécaniciens doivent préparer l'appareil
pour que le pilote puisse décoller de la
base en un temps très court
six minutes 45 après la sonnerie chrono
en main
le mirage 2000 quitte la piste sa
vitesse atteint déjà les 250 kilomètres
à l'heure rien qu au décollage
pendant une semaine les deux pilotes du
groupe de chasse 1 2 cigognes et leurs
mécaniciens vive t'isoler interdiction
de quitter la base et encore moins de
s'éloigner de moins de 100 mètres du
hangar des avions à tour de rôle pendant
sept heures
chaque pilote doit avoir en permanence
son équipement de vol à portée de main
chaque mission est classé secret défense
nous n'avons donc pas eu l'autorisation
de filmer les pilotes
il est un peu tôt un petit peu de stress
parce que parce qu'on parce qu'on sait
jamais sur quoi on les colle un par
contre la mécanisation que notre
entraînement nous nous amène fait que
les gestes viennent naturellement les
équipes sont rodées et il se trouve que
les premières minutes de réaction nous
amène comme comme il a été dit a décollé
et finalement c'est en vol qu'on a un
petit peu l'intitulé de la mission et de
la raison notre décollage provenance
douteuse plan de vol non conformes ou
absence de signal radio le premier rôle
des pilotes et d'établir un contact pour
ensuite transmettre les informations aux
centres de commandement qui se trouve à
lyon
ça va être un niveau de vol ça va être
une vitesse ça va être une attitude un
type d'avion on la décrire sont là
comment l'avion est configuré quels
types d'avions anciens aussi en
connaître on est on est pas on ne
connaît pas non plus tous les types
d'avions et puis ensuite ça va être par
exemple à se rapprocher assez près pour
voir dans le cockpit pour voir si ce
qu'on voit ce qu'on si on voit les
pilotes s'ils nous ont vus si tout le
monde a l'air a l'air d'aller bien ou
alors si au contraire on ne peut voir
par exemple sur des avions qui ont des
problèmes d'oxygène il est déjà arrivé
que des gens voile l'équipage évanoui
ces genres de choses qu'on peut qu'on
peut être en avoir et à la route france
car dès demain les deux mirage 2000 qui
trouve la base de tour pour regagner un
autre port d'attache la base aéronavale
de lorient